hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cybron
tonight we're gonna watch a little game
trailer called the crew the crew the
crew I'm part of a crew a dance crew
yeah I'm a professional real answer yeah
break a break you want a break right now
uh yeah you guys can't see this when I'm
doing amazing tricks right now oh whoa
head spin whoa he's doing the helicopter
coffee grinder [ __ ]
oh he's dead yeah I'm sure that's what
this game is about dance crews fighting
each other not at all really it's not
like step up no it's not at all Oh
funnily enough this is uh what I was
watching I believe oh god please let
this be will be sought from I feel like
an a I'm pretty sure to be stuff when I
was watching their conference my
internet died for an extended period of
time
and I missed like a chunk and of course
the crew was one of the falls that fell
in there but the crew is a recent game
ah most to be really good and it's a lot
about the community building the
challenges and everything as opposed to
like hey now you're gonna race on this
track are you gonna do the easier net
cool I'm hoping all of this is correct
I'm sure you'll all let me know in the
comments down below ends up being some
like gangster story yeah I'm I'm pretty
sure I got the car
the Michael Bay movie the rest
explosions there yeah
that's pretty Wow I have a detail this
cinematic or a gateway I'm actually
pretty sure this is a plane really yeah
that's game play [ __ ] see the thing with
next-gen graphics its I don't want to
say it's TV new cars but cars cars look
great next-gen no this looks very real
it was insanely real oh this is great
dude I'm sure that makes the experience
that was toriel not it but look how far
this is going I know wow you're really
exploring like it's like America it's
close to COEs Wow that is insane really
I guess more in real territory my god I
hope this is great we're driving from
San Francisco great Wow cool couldn't
one play San Francisco rush
sigh
it's get raised River
I asked her
oh here's Elly just got
to burn a lot of really good
that's me that's smart talk about making
a really interactive game just like that
trailer was awesome no was kind of
writing me of the movie drive but it's
like hypnotic la music mm-hmm have you
seen Drive yeah oh you [ __ ]
I'm wearing my drive shirt right now not
damn it I've played a bloke three a lot
okay in it I might apply it's a little
respect for my game ya know that game
does look I love the detail behind it
all yeah like good graphics like that
automatically make the gameplay
experience that much more rewarding
especially if it's a car racing game
yeah I mean if you look at this and if
you look at Forza I don't think they've
shown anything Gran Turismo yet but a
lot of the big racing car games that are
coming out like the gut the cars just
look gorgeous imagine just like just
like everything and you oh you want to
own these cars just so much more got it
like it's really great um I wonder if if
in the future of the creative game we're
using the character who you're playing
as can get roadhead while doing the race
um maybe
but what's and I would want it to affect
the performance of the actual steering
you know ah okay yeah like it like this
whole game is the road head challenge
it's all about getting it and trying to
do your best to stay on course just
every now and then like your vision goes
dark anymore it wrote it that's the name
of the game
we'll start development yeah yeah what
they go quickly want to say is I'm
really really hoping that like you saw
like all these gorgeous like landscapes
and all this stuff and you see the map
of the US I wonder how much of that map
you're gonna get Oh good points if I can
go around and race back in Boise Idaho
we're potato farmer there's I barely saw
many potato farms just a little just
you're disgraced Idaho shame on you
Idaho's my favorite continent that's
right
I'm lying right facts that's why right
if that map is like that detailed and
you can go to like all of these major
cities that's a bomb yeah of course of
course yeah yeah that would be great I
love I'd love to do that well let's pray
on it
dear gaming gods into e3 and all that is
holy please let it allow us to go
everywhere allow us to go ever and in
the words of Johnny Cash I've been
everywhere I've been everywhere if you
needed a channel you can subscribe you
the real rejects here dan has his gaming
channel that cyber channel you can
subscribe here anyway guys it's time for
the shout outs with what the shout outs
it's where we shout things at people
Alexandre sepia he said shout out now or
I will get ELISA to kill you
felissa comes after me I'll slice that
bitch's throat right open you understand
don't you dare send that woman after me
I here with my dick once do it again you
talk like you're going to get the chance
to do that like you wanted you're
talking like you already would I don't
know you know the Pyatt sure it's a
50/50 battle between you and ELISA
I'm just saying she's scrappy she is
scrappy but no I will I have would go
right to the jugular with a knife a
blade sharpened blade I might kill her
right away and I'll be taking bets yeah
and rolling in the cash afterwards
place your bets place Henson and
Alexander thanks for subscribing you
guys shout out and you got your threat
back at you John isn't us in his very
next card he said it shout out isn't
necessary here you got one
MBL designs yo he asked if he could get
a shout-out MBL yes major black league
that's what it stands for the major
black league designs they design
baseball outfits for black plagiarism
baseball league once your hard to come
up with the report skirt you up I'll let
you have it
go ahead yeah but congratulations okay
I'll print out a certificate well major
black leagues thanks for sponsoring us
so it's been any sponsoring cuz uh yeah
you stay classy San Diego and or Detroit
yeah why why Detroit I honestly it was
the first city of akin it was because
there's a lot of black people in Detroit
don't don't do that
don't don't Konami yeah I'm pretty sure
it's it you know I'll have you know
Eminem came from Detroit yeah I know I'm
there eight mile yes is the street